well of course of course that why do you
think I want them to do it on TV because
by the way I don't need our discipline
to win and creative is the variable
right like like I'd be thrilled if TV
one and proved out to be a better medium
for them I'm thrilled let's see it
show me this yes Final Four just finish
so Mercedes Sascha almost hot get this
way alright you guys are saying like
Horus like what I don't have seen Gary I
liked our cadence yesterday up I just
tweeted at you and then you call me
great I think sometimes funny things
happen all right let's do this no sorry
Tommy
it's a pleasure how are you yeah well
yeah I'll meet you yeah I don't think I
appreciate it so time cept I'm doing a
lot in my little small world called the
cross yep
but I have been just like adamant and
growing and through the internet and now
in events and then learning how to
operate as a company has now started
kind of following you'll you in a way
like this angel investments and now
doing more venture investments then it's
an excuse excuse using the platform to
take it to the different learning
flip-flap of course um so let's reverse
engineer like what do you want to happen
like like in a perfect world just in a
decade like how does what does it look
like I think it's like that I think
that's like I you know I didn't even
like I talked about it more now but I
just um how how patient and how focused
I really like everything I've done has
really been hoods like if I'm gonna buy
very expensive sports franchise all my
behavior including massively under
selling this company knowingly a piece
of it to Steven Ross because he was an
NFL owner and that would be an important
piece of the process when you when you
have the humility and patience to leave
tens of millions of dollars on the table
for
you believe in like that's when you know
you're [ __ ] all in this pleasure let
you wanna take a photo yeah took like
that's the most important that has Grand
Slam potential you could have 2.8
million followers amusingly let's figure
out you can't have 2.8 million views on
snapchat you can have 2.8 million views
on musically in six months figure it out
hotel right at the airport wake up and
take your car or would you rather try 45
out you stay in the hotel I'm a hundred
percent
I'm already I'm um I'm all momentum so
I'd rather go yeah you know I didn't
want to all for that but offer that if
they come and see me Friday in the
Hamptons 100% see them okay if they
don't I can't guarantee you yet so I
always have to question well I'm not as
what is not happening here that you want
down where can I sort of insert myself
or even just the large teams of where
can we build ourselves out to make your
vision that so the normal answer to that
question is a lot more tactical you know
it's these specific principles or
regularly their their tactical I don't
give a [ __ ] about that that will happen
in time it's a company than five years
to come from 30 to 650 people like we
know what the front we're doing what's
not happening here is something that's
very important to me what's not
happening here is that we have 615 650
is fluctuating people and not every
single one of them realizes that this is
an all time special place
and that's what I want fixed well in a
world where out of 6:15 I feel like
there's 150 200 people that are out and
at all brought in that's far from where
I wanted to be in fact there's 100
people that are struggling and don't
like it and may not like it that breaks
my heart
and then there's 300 dinner and I want I
don't think people realize what's
actually happening here good yeah great
awesome thank you yeah I wish you well
thank you yeah I'm ready yeah
damnit
yo so guys huh how are you guys is data
Sciences entire backbone based on an
eraser board it says do not erase not
anybody can erase yeah have a great day
guys
huh can somebody get Tyler to get me my
phone
can you give me my phone hey really good
how are you hi I'm done you're in Serina
yesterday yeah because I was with that
three years is that true second if we're
some of my office is a second yeah
that's it it feels like feel like
yesterday well I feel like our our
courtship at South by Southwest six
years ago felt like a good amount of
time so maybe that well cool there for
the first part is look I think one of
the great ways to build a relationship
with me and I'm sure everybody else on
earth is like post game results and
things of that nature it's super
impressive what you're up to at least
you know I'd love to dig a little bit
deeper and understand where you're at I
have a lot of thoughts on to the next
level and thrilled to talk to you about
it I'll probably need some questions
answered so so I can actually give you
some value the 45 people the 17 people
that really run your company with you
that's right the seven you need to know
everything you need to have dinner with
them you need to give a [ __ ]
you need to weep the biggest mistake
people make is not having real
relationships tough conversations easy
ones having the ability to have years
like years a year where it's not black
and white then good years that's a big
big piece of advice that I think people
are gonna lose on they'll be good
thank you yeah all right oh really good
man Tennessee yeah Luke oh I remember
that brother that's really funny it was
like don't worry about it you'll never
get it I remember that man that little
tiny airport oh I love losing it I
[ __ ] love losing oh you can't win as
an entrepreneur unless you love to lose
I love it in it we'll listen I mean
before I mean of course I mean look
anybody watching this or hears that
quote through I get 400 [ __ ] emails
the amount of [ __ ] emails I get when
people like you're wrong Gary Vee like
losing sight like I'm not wrong you nor
stand like if you're scared of the game
you've lost I'll never be a good dancer
cuz I'm scared of what I look like when
I dance like I know what this is about
it's you if you are scared you have lost
like don't even start
that's why I don't I'm not trying to go
to hip-hop class and get better like
it's not going to happen I'm scared of
it absolutely
listen you guys run if you're ever
running I will come on over second to
stop I let me know I love a lot dude
this is [ __ ] awesome this is somebody
who's paying attention to my world
this is a meaningful gift you said but
yeah I love it
I'll ah thanks guys take care man stare
oh hey really good what's up well
where's the call and here all right
readily important it's just a funny
thing to say anyway there's going to be
a lot of people who are about to be
disappointed when they're not able to
reach what they consider being
successful I want to make sure that we
are starting to have a real conversation
about these expectations like it's too
common for people to think that they
have to make or raise millions of
dollars to be successful based
successful business person
so Pam
hey pierce my sneaks so better play
tennis no I use you should play Tyler no
I cannot voice for I have Versailles
yours
Oh can you play yeah no way I grew up on
are you complete Ennis - you guys are
real tennis players but then I'm not
yeah
hey guys on the house house is amazing
dad
bless you
I'm better than good Alison don't get
crazy tonight she's been sitting by the
phone here for him we keep it card of
your face Oh God
list it use my replay
okay like so no way right hello hello
how are you I'm very well how are you I
like the topic are you having a good day
yes I just wanted to say hello and I
appreciate you paying attention to my
stuff and I'm thankful and I hope you're
doing great I love you thank you so much
for putting all that you put into it God
wanted to say hey and I hope you have a
great day thank you you're welcome bye
bye I promise you Jordan we will meet
thank you so much my friend
have a good day
so
yes what good are you good to see you
there golden I met you like I don't know
five years ago it's a pleasure to
conference in Chicago also man how you
doing I'm doing well good ah the the
quintessential can I get a selfie with
ya no he said we had an out I'm heading
to uh I actually just headed in I'm
going to a Google event right right here
see how this works
oh man don't you good to see you I'm
actually I think I'm speaking of this
thing please join me throwing very warm
up thank you very much my mom will be so
pumped if she was sitting here uh thanks
for having me
I think what would be fun is maybe I'll
do a little spiel little context of
where I come from in detail that I think
actually brings you value instead of
just spewing old facts and then honestly
since it's such a small room like I'd
love to do Q&A if you guys want to like
talk about that if there's anything that
I speak about right now that brings
value so I tried to you know every time
I speak I try to reverse-engineer the
room try to understand what the people
in the room would actually care about
and so I think to that bio the thing
that I think would be interesting in
this room is that when I took over my
dad's liquor store they was called
shoppers discount liquors I rebranded it
to Wine Library and and this was 1996
I launched the site in 1996 I took over
1998 and from 98 to 2003 in that five
year window
you know the business was doing three
million dollars a year in top-line
revenue ten percent gross profit so
three hundred thousand dollars before
expenses which meant not only did I
build in from three to sixty million
dollars in sales and five years during
that time which was a very young
internet for the people that have been
around I get it with no money I think
the one difference that continues to sit
in my head compared to what I think is
going on in the ecosystem is I'm
completely agnostic to the platform
where one markets
recognize that creative the variable and
obsess with the context of the platform
to create the variable but I think
there's an enormous amount of romance
and tradition and things that people
hold on to normal okay when it's in the
best financial interest of that person
at least that makes sense to me right
I get more weirded out when it's
literally just ideological and that this
is the way that it needs to be or the
way that I'm comfortable with it being
and so what I mean by that is I've come
to sum up what I do for a living by
saying that I think I now day trade
attention in 2009 I started vaynermedia
because I thought that social media was
gonna get misbranded and it has I would
sit here and tell you that I think
social media is the single worst branded
thing in the world and what I mean by
that is for all of us in this room be
included in our ecosystem and in the
world's ecosystem definitely the
marketing world social media to all of
us and to our clients is a footnote a
sprinkle and afterthought everybody here
if you're here is smart enough to take
one step back and deploy common sense
and if I ask you what is social media
what sites make up this term I think we
would all agree they are the sites that
dominate this device I view social media
as the current state of the Internet
thank you
thanks for having us
I'm getting an uber my first day on the
job we're nice is that right wow it's
awesome man Congrats
well that's fine
I mean I'm super comfortable with that
conversation because if you're testing
1tv execution against one Facebook
execution that's a very viable outcome
and how much in a creative and all that
so I mean what do they want me to do
tomorrow Bridge do they want me to to
explain do they want me to give them
ammo do they believe that this is the
right execution for them like
somebody so good to see you how are you
how are you good
the thing I find fascinating about
reverse engineering is if you know where
you're going
you have a better chance of getting
there
you know if you've been following my
stuff over the last 34 years especially
last couple years like I speak about
reverse engineering all the time it's
just I tell my brain works and I truly
believe it's how a lot of the people
that win do things I do think it's
massively important to know what you're
trying to accomplish
first not waver from that make that the
North Star cut out all the other
[ __ ] no it's black and white
forget the gray forget the distractions
forget the what-ifs
forget the subjectiveness and address
the finish line and then
reverse-engineer it like when you know
what you want you when you know where
you're going and you're not emotional
about it and you don't care what other
people think and you don't get
distracted you can get there if you
focus on it 24/7 365 forever and so I
just want to always know what the hell
I'm focused on where I'm going what I
want to want to do and how do I want it
and within what budget and how and how
many it just reverse engineer what you
want to happen the problems are so many
of you the reason so few things are
happening for a lot of people is they're
confused they don't know what they want
they want 8,000 things they're just
confused
stop being confused figure out what you
want reverse-engineer it and get it